c'est le jour j pour les ad mulder
élèves à la haute école des avocats
conseils de viroflay elle se présente
aujourd'hui à l'oral du certificat
d'aptitude à la profession d'avocat
le cap à une épreuve de déontologie
suivi des soutenances du stage en
cabinet et du projet individuel face à
un jury de professionnels on classe le
candidat fasse une situation concrète de
questionnements des montots logique et
on cherche à savoir s'il a bien acquis
les principes de notre métier ces
principes les ad mulder les a appris en
six mois durant cette période les élèves
sont formés à la pratique du métier
d'avocat ou encore au management d'un
cabinet suivent ensuite douze mois de
stage 6 mois en cabinet d'avocats et une
deuxième période de projets individuels
juridique en partenariat avec une
structure au total la formation dure 18
mois en vient à l'école d'avocat je
m'attendais justement apprendre vraiment
comment me comporter en tant qu'avocat
quels sont justement toutes les
obligations
déontologiques qui s'impose à l'avocat
pour sanctionner cette formation le capa
est composé de deux épreuves écrites la
rédaction d'un acte et d'une
consultation juridique d'épreuves orales
la déontologie la soutenance et
l'incontournable plaidoirie au total 420
heures sont dispensés à les dac la
pénurie de moyens de convaincre de voir
cette force de conviction qui va
permettre dès qu'une aide à la décision
du juge nous et les avocats font 240
heures en plus du programme a posé par
le conseil national des barreaux ce
qu'il faut accentuer me semble-t-il
c'est ce que nous faisons déjà un petit
peu hâlé dac avec la création des
modules approfondie de pratiques
professionnelles et les différents
diplômes et cursus supplémentaire que
nous avons créé il faut impérativement
que nous mettions nos élèves avocats en
situation d'immersion de mise en
situation de pratique professionnelle
les prêts spécialisé à leur avenir au
sein de la haute école des avocats
conseils de viroflay plus de 400 élèves
avocats sont formés en moyenne chaque
année